well guess what
if you think i'm
evil
well this way
till you meet my
variants
[Music]
that's the gambit what is going on
everybody welcome back to the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and mcu i'm your host warren thompson
and today's video is about something
that you may not want to hear it is
about how kang will kill ant-man and
ant-man and the wasp quantum mania this
has been a hot subject lately and i do
think that this is indeed going to
happen but i think there is going to be
a catch to this which we'll talk about
towards the end of this video but first
it's time to revisit some old leaked set
photos from ant-man and the wasp quantum
mania now some of you may remember this
but the ant-man and the wasp quantum
mania stunt team were given shirts for
the movie and on the shirt it shows
ant-man's helmet shattered with the
reflection of kang in it apparently
using some sort of energy weapon that we
can see light coming from could this be
the death of ant-man well since these
photos came out some time ago i have
believed that ant-man will indeed die
and there are several specific reasons
that we'll dive into including how the
director recently said that ant-man 3
will permanently change the mcu they
also showed the ant-man 3 trailer at san
diego comic-con a few weeks ago and the
trailer basically said that kang has
killed many avengers in the past or the
present or the future because ken can
time travel and he does it a lot but
we'll talk more about this in a bit now
recently film theory came out with a
great video about this and they dive
into the actual structure of films and i
really enjoyed it and you guys should
check it out after you watch this video
and ever since this video came out a lot
of people are now talking about ant-man
dying and film theory talks about the
structures of movies and they talk about
these things called pinch points and
they mention that kang has to prove that
he is indeed a very real threat thanos
did this by winning in infinity war he
did this by killing loki and destroying
the hulk this was the pinch point so how
does kang prove himself well kang will
do this by killing ant-man this will be
the next pinch point in the mcu now
let's talk about kang first and how i
believe that many people really aren't
prepared for just how insanely awesome
this villain is going to be to start it
off king has basically millions of
variants kevin feige even confirmed this
he said that we are going to see many
different versions of kang many
different variants of kang and basically
it's not just going to be one kang that
the avengers are going to have to fight
although i do believe that there will be
one superior kang but here's the deal in
the comics kang essentially has a
limitless number of variants and he's
actually able to transfer his
consciousness into another variant right
before he dies essentially making him
immortal which alone makes him a huge
threat but make no mistake kang is worse
than thanos in fact kang let thanos do
everything that he did or i should say
he who remains who is a variant of kang
the conqueror nathaniel richards he let
thanos do everything because he
controlled the tva which controlled
everything in loki season 1 they even
state that the tva let them do
everything they let the avengers go back
in time they said that was supposed to
happen meaning he who remains let that
happen he who remains king is such a
boss that he let thanos eliminate half
of the universe he didn't care because
he knew the ending he knew that the
avengers would go back in time and
defeat him he knew everything which is
what makes him so dangerous but it gets
even worse he who remains wasn't even
really evil but king king the conqueror
is very evil and he who remains even
says if you think i'm evil wait till you
meet my variants well guess what
if you think i'm
evil
well this way
till you meet my
variants
[Music]
that's the gambit thanos at his core was
trying to do something good to save
everybody yes he was savage and trying
to accomplish this plan but kang is
worse kang simply wants to rule because
he's evil thanos didn't want to rule he
wanted to rest after but kang wants to
rule the entire multiverse so we've
established how bad king is and here's
three pieces of evidence that ant-man
will die at the hands of kang the first
piece of evidence is the trailer in the
trailer we know that ant-man when he
meets kang says i don't know who you are
but i'm an avenger kang looks at ant-man
shocked and he goes you're an avenger
have i killed you before this tells us
that kang has gone up against the
avengers before and has killed them it
may not be in our universe it may be in
another universe because remember not
only can kang time travel but he can
also jump to other universes as well and
this is something that spider-man no way
home and multiverse of madness were
actually preparing us for for us to
understand the rules so kang can travel
through time and he can also travel to
other universes and it looks like he's
probably run into a few different
avengers teams and considering the fact
that he is alive i'm assuming that he
has defeated all of the avengers teams
that he's ran into now like i mentioned
kang is essentially immortal which means
he's could have lived for thousands of
years by now heck he could have existed
for millions of years because he can
actually exist outside of time which
means he could have literally gone up
against countless number of avengers
teams this could be why he actually
doesn't remember if he's killed ant-man
before because he's killed so many
avengers in the past he can't remember
if he was one of them and even if he
hasn't killed ant-man in the past this
statement right here proves that kang
will indeed kill he has no problem doing
that at all the second piece of evidence
is the leaked set photo on the shirt i
already briefly talked about this and
it's pretty self-explanatory ant-man's
helmet is busted kang is in the
reflection so clearly he is the one that
caused it this could be the death of him
or this could simply be a very big blow
to the head either way it's really not
looking good for ant-man but the third
piece of evidence is that the director
said that this movie ant-man and the
wasp quantomania is going to permanently
change the mcu now how will this
permanently change the mcu well there's
a few different answers here all of
which can and probably will happen one
is that ant-man will die this will
obviously permanently affect the mcu it
will permanently affect the avengers and
everybody that ant-man knows and
honestly it's going to be a huge shock
to a lot of people if he does indeed die
i don't think a lot of people think
marvel will do that paul rudd the actor
himself is adored by pretty much almost
everybody and he is fantastic
as scott lang ant-man which is why i
believe that nobody thinks he's actually
going to die so his death will
definitely permanently change the mcu
but i also think that his death will
start the young avengers much like it
did in the comics we already know that
his daughter cassie lang is indeed going
to become stature marvel studios
released the first poster for ant-man
and the wasp quantum mania and it
actually has cassie lang in her stature
suit so this is confirmed and cassie
lange is a very prominent member of the
young avengers in the comics it's also
very clear that marvel studios is
setting up the young avengers as we
already have several of them in the mcu
as it is miss marvel kate bishop billy
and tommy from some universe out there
and more but again in the comics the
death of scott lang is actually the
reason the young avengers are formed now
originally when we first heard about
ant-man 3 insider said that this movie
could introduce the fantastic four
however over the past year everybody has
been saying that it's actually going to
be a setup for the young avengers and
the setup could be the death of ant-man
we also know from the trailer that
cassie lane gets into a lot of trouble
and that scott actually has to pick her
up from jail at some point in time and
this is kind of a classic story arc that
we see a lot in movies in general and
that we've actually seen in ant-man
before ant-man was a criminal then he
became a superhero this is kind of
what's going to happen with cassie she's
going to be some sort of a criminal but
go on to become stature but what changes
her what changes her mindset about life
well it looks like it could be the death
of her father so as you can see there is
a ton of evidence pointing towards the
fact that scott lang ant-man might
actually die in this movie but here's
the kicker if he dies they might
actually bring him back especially if he
dies inside of the quantum realm now i
know some people may not like that some
people always talk about well there
needs to be stakes and there's not
really high stakes in killing somebody
and bringing them back but this is
called ant-man and the wasp quantum
mania and we know that they're going to
spend a lot of time inside of the
quantum realm and the thing is we don't
really know how the quantum realm works
that's what this movie is really going
to tell us what we do know is that time
works differently inside of the quantum
realm ant-man inside of the quantum
realm was only in it for five hours but
in the outside world he was in it for
five years we also know that janet van
dyne was changed inside of the quantum
realm and she now has the ability to
somewhat control some type of energy
these are two things that could actually
bring scott lang back one is time travel
two is the energy that could possibly
heal him to save his life or bring him
back to life basically anything is
possible inside of the quantum realm
which is why they could bring him back
now having said that i do think that it
would be much more of an impact and a
much better demonstration of just how
ruthless and strong king the conqueror
actually is if he permanently kills
ant-man now i don't want ant-man to die
but this would severely affect the mcu
and like the director said permanently
change it and i don't really foresee
ant-man and his team being able to
defeat king the conqueror they may be
able to defeat one variant of him but
like i mentioned even if one variant
dies he can simply transfer his
consciousness into another one so they
could temporarily stop him and maybe
modoc who we know is going to be a
villain in this movie as well but i
don't think overall they are going to
win this fight because remember this
movie is kind of the official start of
the avengers the kang dynasty so this
movie is going to show us just how
strong and ruthless kang is and they
might just do that by killing off
ant-man but let me know what you think
about this in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to stay up to date on all
things mcu and don't forget to check out
the video by film theory for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof
me